and it might be fine today but as we
know water moves downwards so what about
three days from now what about next week
right and I think that the people that I
spoke to I don't think that there's
anything malicious about them they were
I think that they are working doing the
best that they can with the information
that they've been given but do I think
that they have the whole picture I mean
I wouldn't if I had to guess I would say
no because I mean the government doesn't
lie right what would happen if the word
got out to I mean this is two-thirds of
West Virginia and not not to mention I
mean almost all of Ohio but like let's
speaking from the perspective of West
Virginia like what do you think people
would do if the word got out that the
water actually was contaminated and they
couldn't drink it oh it's pandemonium
pandemonium would be it would be uh
saying a circus doesn't even do it
justice because it would be way more
aggressively violent and it would have
it just detrimental to to no end you
couldn't even quantify it